як завжди завдяки збройним силам України
з Київської студії марафон продовжує
інформаційна служба Інтера у студії
Олексій Фадєєв Вітаю
ЗНО знову скасовують цьогоріч
український абітурієнти вдруге
складатимуть національний мультиплектний
тест з обов'язкових предметів українська
мова і математика третій на вибір - це
історія України іноземна мова біологія
фізика або хімія тестування
проводитимуть у дві сесії основна
відбудеться у червні додаткова у червні
липні на перевірку знань майбутнім
студентам відведуть три години Ну а
більше про цьогорічну вступну кампанію
поговоримо зараз зі з Сергієм шкарлатом
міністром освіти і науки України він з
нами на прямому зв'язку п міністр вітаю
вас
Доброго дня пане Олексію Дякую вам за
увагу до освіти більше розказати ви в
принципі розказали
[музика]
сьогодні ще не прийнято рішення
Верховної Ради стосовно того що буде
проводитися ммт оскільки тільки Верховна
Рада сьогодні може змінити і
тимчасово Скажімо так замінити ЗНО на
його нмт тому ми чекаємо рішення
Верховної Ради ну Але тим не менше ваше
відомство вже бачить якісь рамки якісь
межі Так якісь нове ціле цього цих змін
і чи може я вас запитати от як саме
проходитиме мультипредметний тест трошки
більш докладно А ну ми знаємо які
предмети обов'язкові для складання І до
речі чому саме історія України випала з
обов'язкових предметів чи є цьому якийсь
раціональне пояснення
доброго ще раз Доброго дня Дякую вам за
запитання адже як будуть проходити це
знову ж таки Український Центр
Оцінювання Якості вищої освіти оформлює
тимчасові екзаменаційні центри в
закладах освіти в інших установах
сертифікаційних центрах можуть бути
створені комп'ютерні класи Де кожен з
вступників обов'язково складатиме
тестування з української мови та
математики А далі
вибір обереж один з таких предметів або
це іноземна мова яка на вибір може бути
як англійська німецька іспанська
французька це може бути біологія хімія
або фізика або Історія України всі три
предмети є універсальними і за будь-я з
яким з наборів цих предметів можна бути
вступати до будь-якого закладу вищої
освіти щодо історії України
Ще в грудні місяці Міністерство освіти і
науки подавав би
проект на громадські обговорення там де
саме історія України була
обов'язковими предметом і це було три
предмети українська мова математика і
історія України а далі четвертий мав іти
на вибір
при всьому під час саме громадсько
обговорення
думок батьків думок викладачів думок
абітурієнтів думок депутатів думок всіх
зацікавлених громадських активістів і
експертів ми все ж таки дійшли це не
один день точилося робота ми все-таки
дійшли згоди що безпекова ситуація є на
першому місці сьогодні і обмеженість в
часі і складання вимоги-складання в один
день і обмежений з часів 180 хвилин саме
на цей вплинула тому що ми залишили два
предмети українська мова і математики
яка в принципі забезпечує об'єктивну і
основну абсолютну
прогностичну валідність і ці ці два
предмети є були обов'язковими в
державній підсумковій атестації тому ми
самі ці два предмети і залишили на
підставі великих суспільних консультацій
але при цьому дає можливість на вибір і
в тому числі і історії України Ми
сподіваємось що в цьому році діти які
готувалися в принципі бачили
[музика]
в минулому році в принципі готувались до
історії України ми таку можливість в них
не прибрали сподіваюсь що вони активно
будуть використовувати предмет історії
України під час формування свого набору
для складання національного мультику
предметного тиску Дуже дякую ну тобто
іншими словами це така своєрідна
оптимізація з огляду на ті умови в яких
нашим дітям доведеться здавати складати
тести а цього року Скажіть будь ласка
дуже важливо
безпека і обмеженість часів це саме ті
вимоги які Ми якраз такі формували дуже
дякую вам
зрозуміло як завжди постає питання як
тестуватимуть дітей які зараз
перебувають за кордоном тобто чи
доведеться їм приїжджати в Україну для
того щоб пройти тести яка процедура
реєстрації на тестування У їхньому
випадку Ну і в яких країнах звісно буде
змога здати тест якщо така змога буде
дуже слушне запитання Дуже дякую вам в
минулому році в нас була можливість в
32-х країнах світу організувати
саме тестування за національними тестом
для вступу до закладів вищої освіти в
Україні в цьому контексті і в цьому році
така можливість залишається ми ще також
маємо надію що ми ще більше розширюємо
кількість країн в яких можна буде під
час перебування в країні для того щоб не
повертатись в Україну а з складати там
національний мультиплектний тест в
початок тестування буде ми плануємо
розпочнемо його Початок реєстрації над
тестування десь в квітні місяці і так
само в інших країнах це можна буде
зробити на сайті українського центру
оцінювання якості освіти з будь-якої
країни світу Дякую вам
про країни світу зрозуміло що робити тим
дітям котрі опинилися цією родина
опинилися над тимчасово окупованих
територіях чи є буде якась можливість
для них
так само як Дуже дякую теж дуже слушне
дуже гарне запитання Я вам дуже вдячний
за такий гострі і в принципі дуже
актуальні запитання в минулому році ми
дали можливість вступати в дистанційно
за співбесіду всім дітям які перебували
на тимчасово окупованих територіях без
виключення і такої можливості
скористалися майже 12 тисяч наших
абітурієнтів вони всі вступали за квотою
два вони всі вступали на місця
державного замовлення єдина вимога що
впродовж трьох місяців Вони мають
все-таки підписати
активізуватись і в закладі освіти
переїхати до університету або
підтвердити своїми документами прагнення
це єдина вимога але впродовж трьох
місяців на сьогодні така можливість
залишається діти з тимчасово окупованих
територій будуть вступати за
індивідуальною співбесідою в режимі
онлайн дякую
ну і звісно чи є бодай можливо якась
попередня цифра приблизна на яку
кількість абітурієнтів цього року
очікуємо
у нас випуск такий самий як приблизно
такі самі як в минулому році ми очікуємо
приблизно 224 тисячі випускників в
минулому році 214 000 із них прийняли
участь в складанні національного
мультику предметного тесту Сподіваємось
що приблизно така саме кількість буде і
в цьому році дякую вам
п міністра вам дуже дякую за ваш час за
вашу роботу це Сергій шкарлет Міністр
освіти і науки України Бо у нас на
зв'язку Дякую гарного за можливості дня
На все добре